you mentioned that you were on Dancing
with the Stars you cannot help your
dating game because I thought it would I
like I seriously took that gig cuz I was
like oh good it's an excuse to dress
like a [ __ ] on TV like I just I'm dock
girlfriend I am for excuses to do that
and the men are very attractive on that
show there is so hot and stupid they're
like so they're not all stupid but
they're just thirst I'm sorry to the men
that who are on that show but they are
they're just so hot and I I love a hot
guy and I keep thinking I can get a hot
guy and I really like I get duped here's
this new trend that's happening with me
is like hot guys that I thought were way
out of my league will DM me like ex
bachelor contestants are sliding into my
deems to be like let's hang out and I'm
like is this my make-a-wish like what is
happening right now these are solid tens
and I'm fine I'm like a comedy 9 so I I
know we had a sliding scale you are a
very attractive woman you you there's no
reason why you can't be with one of
these guys thank you for that I just I
just couldn't even imagine in my wildest
dreams that one of these guys would want
to bang me but I go you know what maybe
I've become famous enough and they and
they are interested whatever so then I'm
hanging out with this guy from The
Bachelor and I'm like waiting for him to
make his move because I've seen his work
on bachelor in paradise he knows he goes
after what he wants and he you've
watched you did your research she
watched the tape like any good
quarterback you watch the tape yeah you
know what you're dealing with do exactly
what I was getting with him he wasn't
doing anything so I eventually was like
are we gonna bang or what he was like oh
I wanted to start a podcast with you and
um which was devastating and I was like
can we have sex and do a podcast like
about I really pitched that and he was
like no I just I kind of I really
respect you comedic ly and when I was
like could you ever disrespect me
sexually is that
[Laughter]